I'll good morning how are you good
morning Dan I'm tired okay well I won't
keep you long but no no you sure you
okay yes yeah but now you're a pitcher
so you're used to working every 4 or 5
days and only going like 6 innings
no I know but when you start up a live
show at 2:40 in the morning it's drink
in my head do you ever get tired like
actually sleepy during a game like
you're let's say you're you're on the
west coast
you ever gotten like just tired while an
actual game that I'm in yeah yeah no no
I was crazy
I got amped up and I was jacked for for
my time but yeah I didn't know 162 games
and not touching a little tired one so
I'm sure never nap during a game did you
no no that's wrong of course you didn't
all right
Dodgers brewers last night fascinating
game the fact that goes to 1 and 13
innings what stood out what's the one
play moment that stood out to you oh wow
there was a lot and I know you know the
Manny Machado stuff ends up being
sidebar I I think probably in the 13th
and it's tough to really you know get on
the managerial moves especially when
you're running out of pitching but I you
know I think the Craig Counsell decision
when Manny Machado got on with the base
hit and there were two outs he there was
a wild pitch he moves to second base you
got Bellinger you got Grand Isle on deck
and then he ran out of players so you
would had to had a pitcher hit so III
think the scenario I know counsel and in
postgame press conference you know
basically said that they were looking to
expand and throw balls and saw that zone
you know it's a long night there were
381 pitches thrown on both teams 16
pitchers used but I think if you isolate
there especially with the open base with
Machado go in the second in a one-to-one
game terrific game both sides both all
the pictures that came in the game were
terrific
I may have probably done the just put
them on grand owl who has been
struggling you know either you decide
the pitch to him or not and I think
counsel admitted that if Bellinger got
on there they were going to pitch they
were gonna walk around owl and then
pitch to the pitcher yeah I think that
really stands out in a two to one game
here's Bellinger talking about being
surprised that they pitched to him
honestly I was surprised that they were
throwing me I thought they're gonna try
and pitch around me give me a swing and
once I saw that they were attacking me
it was just it was kind of grind mode
and dude you can't put the ball in play
and try it in this game I mentioned
Manny Machado here I'm gonna play this
question and answer here about the play
at first base and here's Machado and
being asked about was he purposely
trying to step on it
angular's leg Manny from your vantage
what happened on the play with Aguilar
huh what happened why did you collide
with Aguilar there why I mean you saw
the replay Polly so this pose on a bag
trying to get over him hit his foe
that's 30 out of 30 I mean I don't know
which one Travis Shaw said it was a
dirty play Yelich said it was a dirty
play by a dirty player I wonder what
your response would be to those I play
baseball I go out there I try the one
for my team so that's their comments to
their common so you know I can't do
nothing about that all right I
understand if it's a bang-bang play then
wherever your feet are and you're just
trying to get to the back that was not a
bang-bang play here out no no listen III
don't know whether he was thrown back by
you know somebody we can actually ask
him to question no no when you watch it
clearly for what I wasn't sure what
angular was doing because it wasn't a
bang bang and he stayed on there pretty
long normally you but you know you got a
guy trucking down the line you want to
get out of the way just accidentally
guys have over the years stepped on the
back of a guy's Achilles so he was on
the base that was a little awkward but
clearly you saw Manny you know drag his
left foot after his right foot got on
the bag you know to purpose
we hit into Aguilar I mean I was really
eventually looked rather benign but it
definitely looked intentional so I'm not
sure what Manny's saying would you throw
at him if you were starting today for
the Brewers even though it's playoffs
yes you know that's my concern
Danna I think during the regular season
without question you're he's gonna he's
gonna he hasn't know that there are
pictures on my team that's going to
protect my players we thought that it
was a dirty play and you can't do that
so you know that's the way they spoil
police is it I would be a little
reluctant based on you know where this
series is and the magnitude of what it
means to get to the next round was of
the World Series so I I'm not sure if I
would have to be a directive from the
manager if he was if it was that adamant
and my guess is I think you just put it
in the memory bank at some point you
know next year you you let you let him
know how you feel about it if you're the
Brewers so you would need your manager
to say al I need you to have him wear
one
I wouldn't want now I don't know what
the pregame you know the rules will be
you know if there's ever something
heightened a lot of times the managers
will come to the respective managers or
the umpires will come the respective
managers and say hey listen we know it
what happened last night don't do
anything dumb here because if we got to
toss somebody we will they ran through
16 pictures last night pitching it you
know they're going to need some length
out of both of these teams certainly
wait Miley you know it's been a nice
surprise
with respect to what he's done in the
postseason you know look I think there's
there's a way of showing a guy that you
know don't do that stuff and if it means
you hit him you hit him but you know
there there's a way to come inside
effectively to wake somebody up if I'm
on that team and I know that he
deliberately tried to hurt my first
baseman who's an integral part of my
team it doesn't matter if he's not or
not but the agya Larsen had a heck of a
year you know I would I'd have to show
support for my guy but I'm a little
reluctant on selling again and in a game
five of LCS you know you move on to the
to the World Series so yeah he's a
lighter major league
baseball Network analyst you can see him
on MLB tonight pre and post of the
league championship and the World Series
games how important is this start for
Clayton Kershaw I think they're all
important I think Clayton has battled a
little bit with you know the the pride
aspect if you will with him being you
know generationally the best pitcher
certainly in the last eight ten years
listened and his stuff isn't the same
and I think the anticipation or the
people who watch baseball closely is you
know you're looking at a guy who had a
run that statistically rivaled only
Sandy Koufax with with how dominant he
was his stuff not being the same his
fastball is down discernibly three or
four miles an hour therefore the
differential between his outfits which
is now mostly a slider he throws his
slider very close and speed was Festival
so he's you know he's got a pitch so I
don't know what to expect you know I
think it could be there I hate anything
against the phrase it was terrific
did you see the tweet by mark Mulder a
former pitcher who said and I'm
paraphrasing but he's he's saying as
he's watching in real time
you know Kershaw his last outing he goes
I don't know if he can get I never
thought I would say this but I don't
know if he can get people out with this
stuff and and you would never say that
about Kershaw and that brings me to he
can opt out of his contract but if
you're the Dodgers do you have to look
at this and and say do we want to pay
this guy you know 200 million dollars
for the next seven years or six years I
mean there's a bigger right yeah I can't
imagine him out there now can you know I
mean if you really think about the back
issue you have to go back to 2016 when
it all started creeping in and you know
his innings were down I think he threw
right around 150 you know he hadn't
thrown 200 innings 200 plus innings
since 2015 so that you know those are
serious issues obviously back for any
athlete but as a pitcher and his
delivery was always on Orthodox violent
he's a big guy
you know I cannot imagine him you know
pulling out of that contract you know
he's got you know a few years with some
big-time money and especially now Dan
the way that that we're looking at this
bull penny and the less importance of
starting pitching which I can go on for
30 minutes about that yes yeah no I I
wouldn't imagine it'd be an issue and if
he did I Dodgers you I can imagine that
they would renegotiate that contract Red
Sox and Astros what are the Astros
accused of not really sure
there's definitely something because the
Indians I guess complained that Major
League Baseball about you know somebody
videotaping something and the Oakland
A's did too
and the A's did too right listen I'll
back up here I think it are you
surprised really Dan if that there's
that there's nanotechnology with Apple
watches a couple years ago I guess what
the Red Sox or was that last year I
forget you had the Toronto Blue Jay
incident a few years ago somebody
sitting in the outfield this is where we
are folks I'm going to go back to when
was it when the Ralph Branca I guess
they found out that Boz roster DOMA
zorroski had somebody had a binocular in
center field at Forbes Field or
something like that yeah getting a story
wrong now you might but that's okay
you're on a roll back at Comiskey old
Comiskey with the big pinwheel and there
was some concern back then that there
was some light going on at all should we
allow this though Alba whatever by
whatever means you should be able to try
to steal signs I think to a point I
think anything beyond the lines is
cheating knows it it feels like like how
do I draw the line on cheating if if the
Astros are accused of having a guy in a
position where he wasn't credentialed to
be either taking photos videos and
signaling players on pitches you know
wait nobody here let's let's think of
the lipstick end of the actual timeline
of that how ridiculous that is I'm in
them I'm in the well you're in the
batter's box and I happened to take a
video
don't know how it can all happen within
12 14 16 17 seconds to get to the batter
which ultimately that's what it's all
about
don't be stupid as a pitcher I played
with pitchers and I won't mention their
names but they were relievers and it was
with the Mets that when there was a
runner at second base and the pitcher
would shake the catcher was told to just
put one sign that is dumb you've got a
guy at second base who can easily
transfer the signs right because this is
one at all it's all about communication
with with not a headset which you can
even do a headset anyway because we'd be
talking each other and unlike football
we're across the line of scrimmage
well you have the catcher talking to me
on the mound with the header standing
there so you can't do the heads that'd
be creative with signs because that's
ultimately what we're coming down to but
why do you have a guy there who can
cheat or is trying to cheat if if he's
allegedly can hear alleged I don't know
but this is what I hear and I trust me I
don't have all the information but they
were looking for somebody was
videotaping the dugout to find out if
they had a monitor that was then looking
at the signs that was fixated on the
catcher which again let's go back to use
multiple signs on every pageant this is
where we are and everybody's insecure
and their buddies you know they don't
trust anybody with the first pitch of
the game
don't don't have one sign if you put one
down and it takes three pitches that no
one's a fastball to the curve three is a
slider well you got to be more creative
than that because this is where we are
with technology and ultimately that's
what everybody's trying to steal forget
about bunting and hit and running and
stealing we don't even see that anymore
right now when was the last time I saw
hit and run in baseball
what is the last time you bunted they're
not allowed to bunt as some say berm
attrition will tell you that at 43
percent of scoring better chance you
don't give up an out so we don't even
have that you don't buddy you don't have
hit and running you don't steal unless
the guys really fastened they give them
a green light so what are they stealing
signs it's pitch selection okay we're
the Astros we're the Astros then trying
to see if the Red Sox were cheating is
that what was going on here
[Laughter]
you're punching another lot yeah your
your your punchy here what do you expect
well yeah wait real quick I'm gonna not
belabor it I have a video if you say out
go into the Camberwell and fire a video
into the Red Sox dugout what is that
going to do to help me to get assigned
to the hitter to know what the pitches
that video
what are they video taken I don't
understand well I know years ago they
had Scouts I know that's when I first
got called up in 1987 with the Yankees
they would have a scout that just was
fixated on the third-base coach to
follow his signs to see if they can pick
up actually what the sign is no I
thought that was rather creative right
you're looking at a guy's the third-base
coach he's got a simple sign Rickey
Henderson he had the one o'clock two
o'clock one o'clock bond to clap hit run
three claps deal so like there was
certain simplicity's to certain players
wait the third-base coach that was the
design for Rickey was that simple they
kept it that simple Rick yeah one was
the one was seal to his head run you
know the only one he cared about was hit
and run because he was here at the green
light and I guess bunt
yeah I figure out whether guy was gonna
bunt yeah yeah yeah how's this play out
tonight with Boston and Houston
well how about that
leave a sleeping dog lie and I'd like
Alex Bregman a lot but Nathan of all the
local kid you know from Alvin Texas
comes up big after that you know and I
do like I do like Bregman a lot but you
show me a video now in social media age
and I'm gonna pitch tonight and you do a
back to back to back home run that gives
me a little extra incentive Ivaldi had a
little plus plus velocity my take on
this game is what what do you get from
Charlie Morton he was really the unsung
hero last year in the World Series and
the playoffs he has only pitched four
innings since September 15th got the
shoulder issue yeah he has he had he had
an exceptional year actually on paper
you look at this as a as good a more of
game for starters I can't remember
Porcello couple years ago sigh yeah he's
had a great year and as well as Charlie
Morton so to be another good one really
these are heavyweights battle it out
they're used yeah I
I hope both goes seven games and get
some sleep what time you are you on the
clock today I go on same time after the
delay kid so I'm hoping that it's not
start we start our show at 2:30
we got Trevor power on tonight which
would be really good you know he's a
little scientific guy right with the you
know all the angles and yeah but you
don't like you don't like the analytics
no I do I do I'm not my head isn't in
the sand it's just you know there's
human beings with heartbeats pulse guts
stomach nerves like it's not all about
the exact you know it's not that's
antiseptic it's not and the game there's
a lot of you know really non rhyme or
reason to it you make a good pitch the
guy breaks his batty you know dunks one
in over the third baseman Ted he didn't
try to do that a little swinging bunt
that rolls in front of the third-base
they're like don't get too caught up in
every statistical data because it
doesn't always tell the whole story if
there were analytic guys on your lawn
and you came out what would you say to
them I was a guy that I wanted every
bins I'll give you this because I don't
you know this guy that I'm telling you
going into a game at Wrigley Mark Grace
with the Cubs on lefty batting average
against and I remember because it is
clear as day and it's very simple on
this yellow thing stop using analytics
we're looking at statistics with stats
on certain things I mean it makes it
sound so scientific Mark Grace on two
strikes with the harder breaking ball
from left the unless he was batting 289
on the lefty lefty slower breaking ball
which is the curveball bigger depth
slower velocity he was bat in 130
I mean do you really have to be some
sort of Albert Einstein to figure out
okay I got two strikes I know that that
mark race is not as good as a curve ball
and sure enough boom beautiful day game
at Wrigley dropped a little dewy in
there he rolls over a double play ball
so I mean is it really that hated come
on thank you well we appreciate your
time all right you're a gamer
that's our Leiter Major League Baseball
network for more dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]